one of the things that graphic designers
are trained to do I think is to pass
their trainees to think very carefully
about what's called the difference
between figure and ground so in an image
this figure the bits that stand out if
you like in ground that's typically seen
as the background and there's all sorts
of principles for creating figure and
ground that come from an area of
psychology called Gestalt psychology so
I'm just doing a pattern there and if I
asked you what is that pattern I don't
know how you'll describe it but I
predict that many people would say it's
two squares followed by two squares
followed by two circles followed by two
squares they probably wouldn't say it's
a square followed by two squares with a
gap in between and followed by a square
in a circle with a gap in between or
whatever and that's because the way that
we process images is we use a gestalt
principle called grouping to essentially
group these together so we tend to
emphasize these two as being belonging
to each other there are other that we
rank there for the whole thing now if I
ask you what's that most people would
tend to say that's a circle because we
have a principle called closure where we
look for closure in images we close them
up what's interesting is the camera in
our aesthetic codes out it doesn't
operate on these principles it doesn't
see that as a circle but a human does
and that's the principles that clever
designers start to exploit so they
recognize they can put extra lines and
extra bits here that are nothing to do
with the code that lead your eye to see
these and they can hide the code within
other bits of the image so yeah in this
example there are bits that I think are
the code here there are bits that look a
bit like the code but they're not
because these leaves don't join up so
that to me anyway looks quite similar to
that but to the computer it's completely
different and that's that gestalt
principle of closure that's going on and
they're kind of various others so this
is one of the I think really nice things
about this is that graphic designers
once they understand how the system
works they're exploiting the fact that
human perception of an image is
different from our apps perception of
that image and that those things only
partially overlap and once you
understand
that you can get really creative and
funky about the patterns you make and
that relies on this almost kind of being
a psychological understanding of what's
going on they're not so in a way I
suppose you can make any pattern and
then just make a few changes to make it
fit yes yeah yeah great example ease
once you know the rules we can go back
to my original not very beautiful design
and we can now make it beautiful by
adding a few lovely extra embellishments
around it that actually make no
difference to the image at all I can
extend this out and make it appear
highly significant to your eye but to
our camera that's made no difference and
that's what the designers are doing here
they've got embellishments they've even
worked out that that some of the colors
because our app Maps the image to black
and white that some of these colors here
will map to white and some to black so
essentially they're visible to your eye
but invisible to the camera again so
they even figured out eventually how to
exploit color I think that's a really
nice general point that as all sorts of
computer vision techniques become more
commonplace in the world even things
like the Kinect that we're using to
interact with in games that computers
and people perceive the world in
different ways and that those
differences are sometimes the source of
creativity and those are the things you
can actually kind of if you like exploit
to make really interesting experiences
you